لقد رأيت هذه الصورة على تويتر خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ورأيت الناس يستجيبون
لها، أنت تعلم أنها ليست حقيقية ولكنها بدت
واقعية جدًا وأعتقد أن الشيء
الذي يثير المخاوف بشأنه هو أنك تعرف متى سيستغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً قبل أن نغرق في هذه
التزييف العميق  صور ليست حقيقية،
نعم أعتقد أنها انتشرت بسرعة كبيرة،
ليس فقط لأنها كانت مضحكة
لبعض الأشخاص، ولكن لأن معظم الناس
لم يتمكنوا من معرفة أنها مزيفة، لذلك تعلم
أننا نعرف منذ سنوات ذلك
تمثل الصور التي أنشأها الذكاء الاصطناعي
تهديدًا وشيكًا على الديمقراطية وعلى
المجتمعات التي تعرفها عالمًا
لا يمكننا فيه التمييز بين ما هو حقيقي وما هو
مزيف وما يضعف هذا الصور الفيروسية
للبابا هو أن هذا العالم موجود
هنا، ذلك العالم الذي فيه  الصور والفيديو
ربما لم تعد مرادفة للحقيقة
أه وأنت تعلم أن هناك العديد من
الآثار الاجتماعية لهذا ولكن في الغالب إلى
أي مدى أصبحت هذه التكنولوجيا في متناول
أي شخص لديه هاتف ذكي أه،
نحن على بعد لحظات من مجرد
السباحة في بحر
المعلومات التي لا يمكننا حقًا
التمييز بين ما هو حقيقي وما هو غير ذلك